well obviously it's been frustrating to
get pretty close but not actually to win
it but I'm very proud of the campaign
that I fought and we've built a real
momentum during the campaign but look
we've now reached an outcome and it's
very important for us to unite as a
party and to start the fight back as Tim
said in his speech and I'm confident we
could do that does this mean the party
is now heading to the left and towards
some kind of working relationship with
labour well I think the outcome of the
election with quite a close result
demonstrates that there are many people
in the party you who have sort of strong
views about the issues that I raised
during the campaign and it's very
important that they're reflected as I'm
sure they will be as we go forward so I
want us to be a liberal party a radical
Liberal Party and that doesn't sit very
comfortably in the left-right spectrum
we will challenge both labour and the
Conservatives and fundamentally it's
about giving power to people and power
to communities and that's what we will
be about the reason why I ask is because
David Steele the former leader who was
praised by Tim Farron tonight has
already mooted that idea of establishing
some kind of partnership with the Labour
Party well my view is a liberal and as a
progressive is that progressives across
politics should be prepared to talk to
each other we should not be tribal in
our politics absolutely indeed last week
I met with Caroline Lucas to talk about
how we could work together in
Westminster on the areas where we agree
on the absolute imperative of tackling
climate change on civil liberties on on
Europe but we should be prepared to talk
to people in the labour party as well
but they're going through quite a
tortured election campaign themselves
with what looks like quite a lot of
acrimony and I think it's worth us just
standing back from that for a while
and building our own brand and our our
own values and demonstrating those to
the British people that's I think what
our greatest priority was being Tim
Farron is also a committed evangelical
Christian he's had what some would see
as a small C conservative voting record
on issues such as gay marriage and also
abortion is that compatible with the
sort of liberalism you've been telling
me about well I think tim has been very
clear that he won't allow his faith to
in any way interfere with his leadership
of the party we must always respect
people of faith I happen to be very
different
I'm not fortunate enough in a way to
have a profound faith but the important
thing is liberal values and making sure
that we speak for all the millions of
people across our country who actually
share those liberal values and need a
voice in Parliament what do you see your
role now as the runner-up in this
contest as being well the first thing is
to get a holiday I haven't had a day off
since the 1st of January so it's a bit
Vaccari to be honest and I think just
getting a bit of rest recuperation
spending some time with Mary my wife
watching my team Norwich City will give
me a better perspective on things but
look I'm determined to play my part in
the fight back and I have things that
I'm passionate about I will continue my
fight for equality for those people who
suffer from mental ill-health
something that I care very deeply about
these things aren't going to stop simply
because I haven't won this election you
were a minister and I think many people
regarded you as a strong minister and
minister I knew what he was doing when
it came to the briefs in the health
department nonetheless do you think it
was a mistake for the Liberal Democrats
to enter into that coalition with the
Conservatives no absolutely not I think
we acted fundamentally in the national
interest I think the country is in a
much better place now than it was five
years ago and I think what we will now
see is what a conservative
government is like unconstrained by the
Liberal Democrats so for example in the
budget we've already seen quite a
dramatic cut in the income of people in
work on low incomes as a result of the
cut of the tax credit so this is a very
different government to the coalition
and there's so many things that we
should be proud of the pupil premium
which gets two and a half billion pounds
into schools for children for the
poorest background my work on mental
health cutting tax for people on low pay
these are liberal values that we
implemented in government and we should
be proud of them
Norman lamb thank you